[Música]
Agora saia do vídeo se você gosta de
ficar no superficial. Eu vou te contar
uma verdade inconveniente. O YouTube e o
Conselho de Medicina me limitam. Aqui eu
preciso simplificar, censurar dosagens,
omitir protocolos controversos. Na
comunidade fechada não tem esse filtro.
Eu compartilho os exatos protocolos que
eu uso na minha clínica. Caso e reversão
que pareciam impossíveis, combinações of
label que funcionam. Fornecedores
confiáveis, interpretação avançada de
exames. É basicamente ter acesso ao meu
cérebro médico sem intermediários.
Live semanais respondendo perguntas, PDF
com 47 protocolos exclusivos. Grupo no
WhatsApp. Se você quer a visão funcional
real, sem simplificações
para as massas, clique em seja membro.
Não é para curiosos, é para quem quer
resultados. Agora, se você quer ainda
mais fundo, existe o nível dois. E aqui
é onde separamos quem está brincando de
quem está realmente comprometido. A cada
duas semanas fazemos live de imersão
total com 2 horas de duração, desse
artigos científicos linha por linha,
debatendo controvérsias que ninguém ousa
tocar, revelando os bastidores das
pesquisas que a indústria não quer que
você entenda. E tem mais, seu nome será
mencionado nos vídeos como
agradecimento. Você se torna parte
visível dessa comunidade de elite que
está rescrevendo as regras da medicina.
Enquanto a maioria assiste passivamente,
você estará ao meu lado construindo
conhecimento de verdade, tendo o seu
reconhecimento público como alguém que
investe no que realmente importa. Não é
só sobre aprender, é sobre pertencer ao
ciclo interno de quem está mudando o
jogo. Poucos têm essa coragem. Você tem?
Vamos lá. Vou mostrar como é que faz
para se inscrever no nível dois. Eu tô
aqui em outra conta do YouTube. Eu
digitei aqui youtube.com/c/dralaindutra.
É um dos jeitos de entrar. Outro jeito é
alaindutra.com/apoia.
Bom, se eu clicar assim, eu caio direto
na inscrição, tá? Então vocês vão ter
duas opções aqui, extras mais WhatsApp,
que é o grupo que vocês estão agora, ou
estudos avançados. Se eu clicar aqui
seja membro,
ele já vai pra tela para confirmar
identidade, CPF, data de nascimento.
Eu não vou colocar aqui, não vou
preencher aqui, tá? Mas dando
confirmação aqui, é só dar sequência no
que o YouTube pede, tá? Então é simples
assim.
Se eu fosse
pela outra forma, ó,
youtube.com/c/dralaindutra.
Ou você pode fazer a pesquisa dentro do
YouTube pelo meu canal.